hello and welcome to another great
exciting episode of Google developers
live my name is Arun Nagarajan I'm with
the google apps developer relations team
and we're actually live here from our
studios we have a great partner panda
doc that's joining us and they're going
to be walking us through a great add-on
that they've built for Google Docs and
we'll have a conversation but more
importantly also see a demo of the
product itself but we get started with
some of the technical demos and the
product stuff a little bit about what
the company does what are your typical
products and what are some of the use
cases you're trying to solve yes so we
built panda doc out of the idea that we
have another application that we are
sending proposals and what we realized
is people wanted to send all kinds of
documents they wanted people to be able
to sign common annotate and even track
the document they sent out so that's
where panda doc came from and with the
panda doc google ad on or that add on to
google it allows any document to be
uploaded sent to anyone you choose and
then you can comment back and forth sign
it you know and get confirmation that
they've opened it signed it and you can
communicate right inside so the whole
electronic document workflow exactly
it's all but it's all inside and so it's
just one clean workflow that's great and
who's a typical user and we're using pen
or doc today yes so we created it with
the consumer and SMB in mind okay so we
thought there was like this big gap in
like these these these smaller companies
and and like the everyday user like
ourselves a 25-person software company
sending documents we didn't have these
enterprise applications for doing this
and so we all use we all use you know
the Google Docs and all the other
document storage companies and we said
let's build something that works with
these guys and since we use Google Docs
inside our company and we know a lot of
other consumers and SMBs do we said
let's build it for them and give it to
them for free and have a great product
form perfect and how does the google
add-ons for sheets and for docs rather
helping business like what are some of
the integrations salient points of the
integration so the first one is seamless
integration with your processes actually
so you gotta use
two or three different applications
everything is I done inside Google Docs
the other one is simply sitting it's
very simple as we'll see you later in
the demo how it's done and we have a
really clear you I a lot of people are
complaining that right now the
e-signature software and applications
they're a pain to use we've devised our
move device panda doc with a clearer you
I from the very beginning and this is
the main benefits and we've builded
really fast two guys only a month month
and a half to do and we'll see how it
works alright that's great let's take a
look at the demo yeah absolutely so
we're using google docs ourselves and we
had to use three four five tools to just
send and complete a duck so that's why
we decided to build penna doc and i'll
show you how easy it is to send a
document so I'm sending an agreement to
Dustin for him to sign so let's see how
it works you logging into a Google Docs
and you open your dog so you have penned
a dog menu on the top you open the panel
panel and we will define where we're
going to send it to so we're sending to
dustins so we type Dustin's email and we
need to add several widgets so name it
will be filled by dusting we select an
actor this will be filled by testing
then we will add a date selector which
again will be completed by Justin and
the last one is his signature so we add
a signature block into the document and
when we're done we just click send and
we will be able to insert a small note
to say destiny more want him to do so
we'll just say hey Destin just please
send in this so we can start and all
that's fully integrated into google docs
and I've loved the don't leave anything
that's great so we sent him the dark we
can open the dark in pen attack now to
look at the timeline and this is very
community this is the web app this is
yes this is the web app great and we can
see what fills doesn't has to film let's
take a look what Dustin has to do to
complete the document that so he gets an
email he opens the document
and he can fill the document in three
simple steps he enters his email he
picks the date and then he asks his
signature he can upload his PNG he can
draw he can just select the type
signature he clicks complete the
document and this is it it's done I can
track all the activity i can track when
Destin opens the document we have the
notification we have the dashboard so
whenever somebody says well I haven't
received the document I can say well I
see you have acted and I'll so we give
you the legally binding PDF copy for
your old style users with this
certificate and IP address and the hash
if you had actually printed yeah if you
need to print it that's great that's
awesome I think you mentioned that it
took about a month and a half to build
this yeah about that so ipi is very easy
to use there's really good dick
commendation and let me quickly go
through how it was built yeah let's take
a look so as you can see here the
plug-in itself consists of two sites
yeah the panel yep and whatever happens
on the server right so there's a server
side which is actually script and we
have HTML panel client which talks to
the server side great all the widgets
here we insert them as images huh into
the google doc and will link them to the
appropriate instances independent OCH so
when you click send all the images will
be transformed into HTML slices in pana
doc which you're the assignee can fill
in and sign them like so in a nutshell
this is how it works that's very cool
thank you very much for sharing all the
details of your ad on and also some of
the business context of why you built
the side on what you're looking to get
out of it I've personally use the add on
and I think it's a really awesome add on
these guys have done a terrific job good
luck with the launch and we really hope
you guys out there check it out and give
us a lot of feedback on it thank you
very much thank thank you
you